I think everybody thinks that they've
witnessed my most embarrassing moments
cuz I fell on my face yeah getting an
Oscar and then I fell the next year on a
cone my most embarrassing moment um was
during Silver Linings year like award
season it was one of those you know
parties and yeah and um so I'm just like
in a corner like drinking champagne an
older woman approached me and in my head
I just
went this is Elizabeth Taylor who who
was dead at the time who's still dead
all right well we didn't say anything
did you yeah yeah and so she's
complimenting me she's complimenting me
and I was like I was like me no I mean
you your movies that I can't name I was
like you're unbelievable and then my
friend walked by and I grabbed her and I
was like this is Elizabeth Taylor and
she was like no it's not